hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be taking a look at five Draco
Malfoy theories that have recently
caught my eye to start I'd like to
acknowledge that there are loads of
debates out there between fans as to
whether Malfoy was a redeemable
character or not there seems to be two
very distinct camps one that believes
Draco was a snake at the beginning of
the series and an even bigger snake at
the end and another that believes he was
simply brought up in an environment of
hate but was really a good person the
latter of these two groups suggest that
there is a very obvious character Arc
and redeeming storyline that Draco goes
through in the latter half of the series
I must admit that I'm somewhat with the
second group of fans in my beliefs
regarding Malfoy sure he was a pompous
pure blood that did Terrible Things to
Harry and his friends in their youth but
these terrible things were always done
with juvenile intent for example in the
philosopher stone Draco was responsible
for tricking Harry into thinking he was
going to fight Malfoy in a midnight duel
but his true intention in challenging
Harry was to have him found outside of
bed running around the castle after
hours something which would have
resulted in Harry's expulsion expulsion
not death not even harm so I imagine you
take my meaning Draco seemed to hate
Harry but not to the point that he would
cause him actual harm at least as an
11-year-old boy of course later in the
series there are many times in which
Draco is presented with the opportunity
to bring harm to Harry such as when he
was asked to identify if a very badly
stung Harry was indeed the Harry Potter
this happens at Malfoy Mana in the
Deathly Hallows after a group of
snatchers find Harry Ron and amione in
the woods and they use a charm to puff
up Harry's face beyond the point of
recognizability of course the snatcher
suspected Harry his lightning bolt scar
mly to blame but when Draco home from
school school on holiday is asked to
confirm that the puffy faed adolescent
wizard is the Harry Potter he falters he
knows it's Harry we know he knows but he
does not confirm it to his father Lucius
even though it would have brought the
Malfoy family back into great favor with
the Dark Lord because Draco knows that
if he were to identify Harry as Harry he
would have been killed this is one of
the most telling moments to the true
nature of Draco Malfoy and so it's with
this perspective that I'll be taking you
through today's theories on Mr Malfoy
five Draco helped Harry in the Chamber
of Secrets this Theory only pertains to
the movie however it's possible that it
was some secret narrative in JK
Rowling's mind as she wrote the novel
since she had a hand in the films and
was known to share backstory with the
actors and filmmakers as necessary the
theory stems from a small moment in the
movie that didn't happen in the book
when Harry herione and the Weasley went
to flourish and blots to buy their
textbooks and ran into the malfoys Draco
can be spotted glancing around the shop
to see if anyone is looking before
ripping a page out of a book of course
this on its own means basically nothing
but if you put that together with the
fact that later in the Chamber of
Secrets Ron and Harry find a petrified
herione with a ripped page about
basilisks in her hands one may begin to
see a connection the obvious assumption
that most people have made regarding
this scene is that Hae must have found
information on the basisk torn out the
page and been on her way to find Harry
and Ron when she was attacked but when
have you ever known herione Granger to
tamper with the sacred entity of books I
must admit I do find it rather difficult
to imagine her doing something so
careless to a thing she held in such
high regard now back to Draco and his
ripped out page why would he have done
this if he wanted a page from a book
surely his wealthy father could have
bought him the whole damn thing well the
theory goes that since Lucius Malfoy had
been talking openly about the dangers
abounding at Hogwarts for muggleborn he
must have been aware of or at least the
myth of a basilisk and other creatures
associated with Salazar sutherin lurking
within the castle so perhaps in an
effort to learn more about what he had
overheard his father talking about Draco
ripped out a page on the giant serpents
then when he realized just how much
danger the students at Hogs are in he
found a way to get it to herione for her
to share with Ron and Harry knowing that
they would try to stop it it I suppose
there's always the more Sinister
possibility that Draco hoped the three
would go looking for the Basilisk if
they knew what to look for that is and
would then come to harm when they
encountered it four in year seven Malfoy
was hogwart's head boy I'll be the first
to admit that this is a rather benign
Theory however it's a theory nonetheless
in what would have been Harry Ron and
Hermione's seventh and final year at
Hogwarts there's the thought that Draco
Malfoy may have been the school's head
boy this this role is typically
entrusted to a senior prefect which we
know that Draco was prior to his seventh
year there's also the fact that Hogwarts
was being run by Death Eaters at the
time and therefore Malfoy would have
been a suitable pupil to fill the role
what with his family's allegiance to the
dark lord to anyone who questions
whether or not Draco even attended
Hogwarts in his seventh year we know
this to be true for several reasons one
of which is the fact that Lucius Malfoy
says to the werewolf gryback in the
deathly Hallows that Draco is back from
school for Easter holidays three Draco
was never a Death Eater now since Theory
number one in this video was only really
for the movie franchise this theory is
strictly for fans of the novel if you've
seen the Harry Potter films then you
will have explicitly seen a dark mark on
draco's arm but in the books whether or
not Draco has a dark mark is a lot more
Up For Debate you may recall a previous
Theory I've discussed in another video
that Draco might have been a werewolf
and that the mark on his arm which in
the book Harry never got a good look at
was actually a werewolf bite from
greyback this is just one of many
theories offering alternatives to what
could have been on draco's arm if not
the mark of a death heater in my opinion
considering the direction and
allegiances that Draco chooses to make
after the battle of Hogwarts it seems
all the more likely that Malfoy never
actually pledged himself to Voldemort
making me quite open to the idea that
Draco was not an official death Peta two
Harry was in love with drao Malfoy in
the past I've explored the theory that
drao was in love with or at the very
least had a crush on herione but this is
a new one for me apparently actor Tom
Felton the British actor who portrayed
Draco Malo in the series has said he
believes this particular fan Theory to
be true now I suppose Tom could have
been being glib since he says this in a
somewhat sarcastic manner alongside
Harry Potter co-star ruet grin who
played Ron in the series the two actors
laugh as they make the Declaration that
Harry and Ron must have been mad for
Draco with all the attention they gave
him the theory hinges on a similar basis
to the Draco was in love with hmane
theory that because of all the attention
Harry gave Draco throughout the series
perhaps his strong feelings were fueled
by something other than hatred there's
also the fact that Draco was so easily
able to get under Harry's skin another
quality often associated with an
individual having intense unwanted
feelings for another now I'm not saying
that I accept this Theory to be true but
if it were I can see possible supporting
evidence in the way Harry behaved
towards Draco number one Draco Ron and
Harry are all distantly related now this
Theory makes the previous one a bit
awkward there are several fans out there
who have voiced that they believe since
there are only a limited number of pure
blood visiting families in the world it
would have eventually become impossible
to remain a pure blood without marrying
a relative however distant that relative
may have been in reality there's
actually more proof to this Theory than
just the aforementioned speculation for
cedrella black was married to a septus
Weasley the two had three children one
of whom was likely Arthur Weasley who is
of course Ron Weasley's father draco's
mother was n Sissa black before she
became Mrs Malfoy and James Potter was
born from the black family lineage as
well but that all together and you got
Draco Ron and and Harry all descending
from the Black family tree in one way or
another and with that we've come to the
end of another video what did you think
did I miss any theories about Draco Malo
that you think are worth discussing
please share your thoughts in the
comments below and as always if you
enjoyed this video don't forget to like
it and subscribe to the channel until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forget to
live